el Papa Francisco fue aclamado con
fervor a su llegada en papamóvil al
estadio de los mártires aquí en
quinchasa el más grande del país y uno
de los estadios más grandes de África a
este encuentro asistieron unas 65.000
personas Francisco se dirigió a los
jóvenes congoleños les pidió que
creyeran en su país y que se
comprometieran a construir el futuro de
la República democrática del Congo Dios
ha puesto en sus manos el futuro de la
sociedad les dijo Francisco y de este
gran país el pontífice instó a los
jóvenes con coleños a preguntarse Cómo
puedo servir a mi comunidad y a mi país
una pregunta a la cual el pontífice
respondió invitando a los jóvenes a
dejar de lado el espíritu del
individualismo a decir no a la exclusión
a la discriminación al regionalismo y al
tribalismo dijo Francisco que son la
negación de la comunidad más del 60% de
la población de este país tiene menos de
24 años los jóvenes son el alma de la
República democrática del Congo esta
tarde está prevista una reunión de
oración con un grupo de sacerdotes y
diáconos y seminaristas que encontrarán
al Papa Francisco en la catedral